I discovered some mold. I had spilled coffee the first time I tried a coffee
animal in the shower. Um, and in the bathroom I discovered mold and we
cleaned it up right away. Should I be concerned if there is more mold that is not
visible? The spill was right where the fluoride connects to the tub and the
fluoride is a bit loose. So, um, should you be concerned if you find mold
in this case, or where this person found it, or if you found mold underneath your
sick, or if you found mold, and you cleaned it up and you got rid of the mold,
should you be concerned about Michael toxins? Um, I would say, maybe, but maybe
not. Remember, mold is going to grow quite quickly. Bold spores are free
ubiquitous. Bold is going to grow quite quickly when you have water and
contact with organic material. And grout and concrete is organic material.
Typically, mold's not going to really grow on your tile if it's glazed, but it
can grow on any wood surface, any trim wood that you have in your bathroom.
Baseboard wood trim, uh, it can grow in your shower, on your grout, mold can grow.
So, you should be cleaning it under regular basis so that it doesn't.
Now, does that mean that you have Michael toxins being dispersed from that?
Well, it really depends. There's a lot of this there. Um, and how big of a spot it is.
So, that some of the things that start measurable, if you did it in a
mutolytic slab and you put a petri dish in the bathroom, even after finding this
little bit of mold, there's, it's very possible that it's going to come back,
you know, less than 10 parts per million, which is negligible and you don't have to
do anything about it. So it is extremely common that you have little spots of
mold, maybe in the quarter or your bathroom that you have to clean on a
fairly regular basis. Um, and, and that doesn't mean that you have a
moldy house. It doesn't mean that you have a lot of
Michael toxins in your house. It doesn't mean any of that. Now, if your
Michael toxin test was extremely elevated, it still doesn't mean that's where
you got them. So it's very difficult to discern where one could have
gotten Michael toxin exposure because Michael toxins
are exposure comes from so many different sources. So it's, um, it's, if you have,
you know, a do an immunolytic test where you put the petri dishes around your
house and you have spots that are extremely high, well then you have to try to
mitigate that problem. Um, but for the most part, most people that do that test,
it doesn't come back high. Um, and if it did come back high,
the person already knew that they had a mold issue in their house
most of the time. So I would say no, typically that isn't
an issue. I would just keep an eye on that spot. That's why I think it's always
going to do a cursory examination of your house. We look for any areas where
moisture is coming into contact with window,
trim, or something else in a, uh, for long period of time where mold could start
growing and trying to keep things clean. So this is, you know,
dealing with mold and dealing with keeping mold out of your house,
really is, uh, cleanliness is next to godliness, or we should say,
cleanliness is next to moldlessness. And that's
that can be a prevention can can really be, uh, help. But I wouldn't be concerned like,
oh my gosh, we found mold in this spot. Well, I cleaned it up. Is that, uh,
something to be really concerned about? No. Um, but if it persists, if, if something
is, you know, you find a really bad spot that you didn't know about,
that you have this giant black mold growing underneath your sink,
and you'd ever, noticed it, you'd ever looked under there. It was behind
something that yeah, that, that can be a concern. Uh, so
those are the, those are the kind of ways that you would assess that.